ce soir avec jean bédard qui est le
président de la cage et claudine roy
propriétaire de l'auberge sous les
arbres à gaspé présidente de
l'association restauration québec ton
soir bonsoir madame roy d'abord le
message du premier ministre semblait
clair aujourd'hui gravos il ne semble
pas enclin à rouvrir rapidement votre
réaction à cela et vous savez ont mis
tout de même content d'avoir pu attirer
l'attention du premier ministre
aujourd'hui sur cet important enjeu que
notre industrie de la restauration
on s'attendait pas à voir une réponse ou
la réouverture bien sûr ce midi mais le
fait que le premier ministre a quand
même pris notre dossier ils l'ont mis au
dessus de la pile
nous en sommes très conscients très
content est conscient de tout ce qu'un
premier ministre à faire aujourd'hui
avec cette qu'ovide on attend une
réponse en début de semaine alors pour
nous bien sûr mais sans présumer sans
présumer de ce qu'il va dire madame roy
aujourd'hui dit on est à mille cas par
jour
c'est grave il faut augmenter le
télétravail
monsieur bédard est ce que le message
c'est que le 28 jours va se prolonger
mais écoutez je pense que c'est clair
qui risque de se prolonger un petit peu
puis et de toute façon comme roissy
on sait pas aujourd'hui sa part des
postes qu'ils nous disent qu'on rit ou
veut demain de toute façon les
restaurants besoin d'avoir un peu de
temps pour se préparer et ne s'est pas
une industrie où on ouvre on ferme si
facilement on a des denrées on a des
productions à préparer mais comme comme
claude janaudy que le premier ministre
prenne la peine de parler de notre
industrie aujourd'hui ça nous rassure
parce que je pense pour on voit vraiment
comme un conte est important dans la vie
des québécois puis nous ce qu'on veut
faire pour ne pas eu de réponse
définitive faut donner du temps je
pensais des décisions que sont
extrêmement important pour le
gouvernement
on veut leur donner du temps pour qui on
est sûr qu'il faut pouvoir continuer
nous de marteler sur le message qu'on a
délivré ce matin qui est qu'on peut
ouvrir de façon sécuritaire
cela dit claudine roy la fermeture la
fermeture des restaurants des bars les
fermetures qui ont été annoncées depuis
le début du mois d'octobre
est ce qu'on constate aujourd'hui que ça
nous a permis d'avoir un meilleur
contrôle et là on arrive un plafond on a
de la difficulté à faire baisser la
courbe mon moi on a l'impression qu'on
monte pas davantage moi je peux vous
dire gerald ce que j'observe ici dans
mon lieu est ce qu'on peut voir à la
grandeur du québec
je ne crois pas eu le fait de fermer des
établissements de restauration que c'est
ce qui a fait augmenter la cour très
honnêtement on ne me les mesures
sanitaires très strictes pour tous les
restaurateurs on a travaillé très fort
en avant avec la santé publique la csst
et le mapaq quand on est ouvert le 15
juin dernier les restaurateurs ils y ont
fait un travail colossal
on arrive dans un restaurant aujourd'hui
on se désinfecte on ne mourra je suis en
état cyan deux textes qui glace le
serveur et lunettes les masques et tout
ça mais c'est pas suffisant semble-t-il
c'est pas suffisant semble-t-il le
groupe c'est là que le bât blesse c'est
là qu'il faut faire quelque chose et
c'est là que nous nous on dit ça n'a pas
de sens qu'on soit victime
présentement au niveau de la santé
publique
je pense qu'il faut il faut aussi va
mettre les pendules à l'heure or on n'a
pas eu de cas d'éclosion on avance y
habitent ou travaillent en impôts lui
durant les trois mois de verture des
restaurants alors pourquoi encore où
elle nous confiner vous savez gérable si
on est fermé le mois de novembre est le
mois de décembre
c'est ça va être la mort de ce prêtre
conviennent restaurants au québec alors
que moi je suis en gaspésie oui capitale
pour la prison c'est quoi l'avenir de
votre entreprise monsieur bédard de la
cage qu'on connaît là je sais que
pandora qui en ce moment mais ça change
en rien la vôtre vit présentement est ce
que vous êtes même en train de perdre
vos employés ben c'est surtout ça je
dirais que on est quand même préparé on
s'attendait cet automne à avoir cinq six
mois
en dents de scie avec justement le
bateau du véreuses qui les chantent plus
plu - les terrasses fermées sont est
impressionnant ce qui nous inquiète le
jugerait que deux choses la première
chose c'est que nos employés la première
fois étaient confinés comme tous les
autres industries en ce moment il se
demande comment ce fait nous on était
confiné à faire plus d'efforts puis à
d'autres industries qui sont ouverts
sont tentés de regarder pour justement
changer de secteur parce qu'ils y ont
besoin aux autres de travailler envoyons
des cartes à payer comme tout le monde
c'est la première chose qui nous
inquiète la deuxième c'est nos
fournisseurs également qu'ils sont des
jeux étaient déjà très impactées par la
première vague
la première fermeture est ce que dans si
nous dit je prends mon endroit semaine
vous ouvrir dans quatre semaines
est-ce qu'on est encore en mesure de
faire ça pour ce que nous on a lancé un
cri du coeur aujourd'hui l'appui on
avait déjà fait des beaux financiers
dont on a fait beaucoup d'efforts vous
avez des programmes pour nous aider sur
les apprécie beaucoup dans ces
circonstances mais c'est beaucoup plus
respect humain et la de nos employés et
des fournisseurs pour vous les mecs en
valeur aujourd'hui l'industrie comme
l'ont montré qu'il faut vraiment avoir
une visibilité rapide pour s'assurer de
ramener un peu de confiance dans la dans
la tête des gens qui dépendent de cette
industrie là qui est important et on
parle beaucoup de la santé psychologique
qu'on va terminer là tu la santé mentale
madame roy de des travailleurs des
clients des citoyens également qui est
en jeu c'est très important on voit des
employés dans nos établissements qui
sont anxieux en dépression dans sa foi
capables nous allions nous avons
travaillé avec une clientèle assez jeune
alors c'est très important pour cette
clientèle là de les remettre au travail
ils savent qu aujourd'hui coiffeur où
aller alors pour nous c'est la santé
mentale des québécois et québécoises est
aussi très très important bientôt
provini visible sur la copie mais il
faut se donner des moyens pour vivre
parce que vous savez la cause ijaw on en
a peut-être pour sinon on verra ses amis
mais qui sait ce qu'on va faire c'est
bien ça d'incertitudes et la complexité
qui grandit en ce moment c'est huit mois
plus tard monsieur bédard madame roy
bonne chance et merci
cwi